President Trump says his repeated
lashing out at his critics and perceived
enemies is not to blame for encouraging
the actions of the package bomb suspect
even though says our seoc was one of his
fiercest supporters on Friday the
president called for national unity but
hours later he attacked the media and
complained that the focus on the bombs
was taking away from the upcoming
midterm elections we too Jiang is at the
White House good morning WETA good
morning Michelle and good morning to
everybody president Trump has sent mixed
messages since those suspicious packages
first surfaced wavering between a softer
tone and angry accusations last night he
said the media is using the sinister
actions of one individual to score
points against him and the Republican
Party as you know the suspect has been
captured great job at a campaign rally
in Charlotte last night president Trump
congratulated law enforcement officials
for a quick arrest in the wave of bomb
scares and once again called for unity
everyone will benefit if we can end the
politics of personal destruction
we must unify as a nation and peace love
and in harmony then the president
immediately pivoted to playing the blame
game
the media's constant unfair coverage
deep hostility and negative attacks you
know that only serve to drive people
apart and to undermine healthy debate
right before taking off for North
Carolina mr. Trump denied having a role
himself I did not see my face on the van
I don't know I heard he was a person
that referred me over others but I did
not see that
and he defended his frequently fiery
rhetoric well I think I've been toned
down you want to know the truth I could
really tone it up because as you know
the media has been extremely unfair to
me but mr. Trump has not pulled back on
Twitter at 3:00 a.m. on Friday he
accused CNN a recipient of a suspicious
package of attacking him writing yet
when I criticized them they go wild and
scream it's just not presidential and
just moments before the FBI arrested
Caesar's say yak hero Republicans are
doing so well in early voting and at the
polls and now this bomb stuff happens in
the momentum greatly slows the president
tried to clarify and shift the focus
back to the midterms the place has
happened where people talk about was
that and rightfully so it was a big
thing rightfully so but now
we have to start the moment to begin in
fact president Trump is hitting the
campaign trail hard with at least ten
more rallies planned before Election Day
he was asked if he plans to personally
reach out to some of the people who the
bomber targeted like Hillary Clinton and
former President Barack Obama the
president says he thinks he'll pass
anthony rizzo jiang at the White House
we just thanks